hi I'm Mikey I'm Timothy I'm Elena I'm
Spencer and we are here to play screw
marry kill with inanimate object we've
been together for three and a half years
six months tomorrow
oh six months tomorrow oh oh I already
know she's already know so she's my oh
yeah I was gonna screw the course well
maybe I should definitley screwing this
Oh
it looks like it would be the most
exciting by far this thing's got some
class so I'm gonna say Mary yeah just
kind of by default sadly I would
probably marry the phone
it just seems nice to be with this is
good to look at the phone I think how
did it know but it looks nice I would
screw the phone probably so I'm just
gonna have to kill that for this thing
yeah okay yeah I'd kill it it oh that's
so sad though look at its eyes like
that's tough my first instinct was to
marry the cat is it's cute
as far as screwing this one's just like
sexier I'm gonna screw this and kill the
coral I think I would kill the coral cuz
I don't think I could do it to this guy
my god you would kill i would kill it
okay cool it's already dying well there
you go then just put it out of its
misery okay well I just bra
there are some people that are going to
take the city overly serious
this is harder cuz West in time I'd made
one because I just I have an obsession
with bouncing things all of that sounds
weird when I say it out I think I would
also the ball the ball is like it keeps
you occupied so you just like wanna
marry something that just keeps you
occupied yeah I think I'm good what oh
okay
screw I don't know if it's for the shape
or the fact that it has a little shiny
man on it it just makes no sense to me
from there the tennis ball just seems a
lot more fun than the small trash bin
which I would then you know have to kill
I just don't like it it just reminds me
of being like you both a little leaguer
little league was fine but just at the
end of every year you get a trophy and
it was just like oh I don't need you
thanks for that I don't know I think I'd
kill it I think I'm gonna go with screw
this one I don't know if it's like you
know you took something phallic and this
one maybe suggest the opposite also I'm
a very clean person by nature and only
this kind of it turns me on so I would
marry screw kill screw marry thank you
screw marry kill screw marry kill
if you have to plug it in I'm screwing
yeah I plug into something that points
it obviously we screw the robot it's
pretty hot I'm gonna marry this car
which is you know a really pretty car
and I'm gonna kill that the thought of
screwing or marrying and it scares me
and also definitely hurt myself a lot of
those before
those gonna be bad vibes okay there are
other ways okay he said you wouldn't
marry that yeah I would you would kill
that I think it's not like I would why I
wouldn't want to kill it but I would
kill it just because like you have such
good options here you know I'm gonna go
with the the danger element again it's a
screw this some kind of deviant I I you
know I just want to keep it interesting
this beautiful car here I think I'm
gonna go with Mary on that kill yeah
robot I know he's not well-intentioned
you and I kill them cuz I want to scream
also that is also the jealousy in
conclusion screw marry kill scream marry
screw marry kill yeah screw the beader
marry the car and then I would kill iron
jaw no we both kind of picked the safe
classy things as what we would marry
which says something okay yeah you know
I was expecting inside to see me in
tears we didn't have a lot of the same
answers except for I murdered the coil
honestly like that
[Music]